la policía de guatemala detuvo el
viernes 29 de julio al periodista josé
rubén zamora el presidente y fundador
del diario del periódico las autoridades
también allanaron la sede de este medio
de comunicación que había presentado
pruebas de la supuesta implicación del
jefe estaba alejandro giammatei y el
fiscal general consuelo porras en casos
de corrupción y abuso de poder el
portavoz de la fiscalía juan luís y
pantaleón aseguró que zamora fue
arrestado en el marco de una
investigación por lavado por lavado de
dinero chantaje y tráfico de influencias
además de conspiración y destacó que no
está relacionado con su trabajo como
periodista saludamos entonces a nuestro
primer invitado del día ls carlos jornet
presidente de la comisión de libertad de
prensa e información de la sociedad
interamericana de prensa gracias juan
carlos gracias carlos perdón por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 de preguntó entonces la
situación actual de josé rubén zamora y
la libertad de prensa en guatemala en
torno a este caso
bueno muchas gracias revaluar por
ocuparse del tema bueno sin duda que una
señal de alerta muy grave lo que ha
ocurrido con el caso del periódico y de
jose rafael zamora nos preocupa no sólo
por lo que ha ocurrido sino por lo que
puede llegar a abrir de aquí en más en
más allá de las razones que se invocan
desde la fiscalidad es evidente que hay
un intento de criminalización del
periodismo una práctica de acoso
judicial
lohan y en ese sentido es imposible no
ver
enormes similitudes con el proceso que
se viene desarrollando en nicaragua y
también con el que vive venezuela desde
el gobierno de hugo chávez para acá no
son situaciones muy similares
con signo ideológico distinto con
procesos tal vez y se han ido
desarrollando de otro modo pero si uno
mira la espectacularidad del
procedimiento la irrupción en la casa de
josé rubén y también la redacción del
periódico
el embargo de las cuentas del periódico
recuerdan episodios similares impulsados
por la justicia de nicaragüense y que
fueron el preludio
de una campaña de persecución del
periodismo independiente en ese país
carlos también le quiero preguntar a
digamos si hay en guatemala otros casos
parecidos o si hay digamos hay unos
periodistas que están ya fichados por el
gobierno a lo mejor por las autoridades
por precisamente sacar a la luz estos
presuntos casos de corrupción que
involucran a las altas esferas del
gobierno
bueno el gobierno de giammattei no se ha
caracterizado por
digamos garantizar el libre ejercicio
del periodismo en el país y esto que
está ocurriendo por eso les decía en una
circunstancia que puede marcar
un punto de diferenciación de lo que
venía ocurriendo hasta ahora un punto
donde comience a acelerarse el proceso
por eso le recordaba lo que ocurría en
nicaragua porque empezó de forma similar
si existían razones como se dice como
alega la
fiscalía general para imputar a zamora
en su condición de empresario y no del
periodista debió garantizarse de todos
modos el debido proceso y no afectarse
en modo alguno la reserva de las fuentes
de información y de los apuntes y
archivos personales y profesionales que
la verdad está muy en cuestión por el
modo en que se ha desarrollado este
procedimiento no todo eso es exigido por
el punto 8 de la declaración de
principios de libertad de expresión de
la comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos y la verdad insisto hay una
aparente violación de protocolos básicos
y no es de extrañar porque el fiscal
general
consuelo porras
tiene un historial de enfrentamientos a
jueces y fiscales que investigan
presuntos hechos de corrupción
hay periodistas que investigan en
guatemala y a partir de esto creo que
hay una señal muy fuerte de que el
gobierno puede llegar a ir por ellos
claro e incluso carlos recordemos que
ayer también fue cancelada esta
audiencia donde esta periodista iba a
brindar digamos en su declaración
también organizaciones de derechos
humanos de libertad así también de
prensa aseguran que fue cancelada esta
audiencia para precisamente mantenerlo
en la cárcel cuál es su posición y qué
piensa respecto
bueno por eso le hago el paralelo con lo
que ocurre en nicaragua claro y las
mismas acusaciones del lavado de dinero
son las que mantienen en una mazmorra
desde hace un año al gerente general de
la prensa de managua y que es además
nuestro vicepresidente regional en ese
país juan lorenzo holman chamorro no
esto nos lleva a exigir que el gobierno
de alejandro giammattei
asuma el compromiso público de que no se
utilice indebidamente el poder del
estado para presionar o castigar a
periodistas y medios de comunicación en
función de sus líneas informativas como
sostiene el punto 13 de la misma
declaración del principio que mencionaba
recién o en otras palabras
debe evitarse toda presión directa o
indirecta dirigida a silenciar la labor
informativa del periódico y del
periodismo en general en guatemala que
es lo que hoy está en cuestión
carlos también le quería preguntar por
la situación general de nuestra región
además de nicaragua como también es
evidente nosotros incluso tuvimos al
editor en jefe del diario la prensa a
quien nuestro programa para hablar
precisamente de la situación del
periódico más allá de nicaragua a
venezuela pues digamos cuba- cuales
otros países están digamos en peligro a
la libertad de prensa últimamente
en américa latina hay varias situaciones
que preocupan que generan alarma
además de estas cuestiones de
persecución de acoso judicial
de forzamiento de exilio porque en
nicaragua hoy llevamos casi un centenar
de periodistas o directivos de medios
que han tenido que huir del país lo
mismo que ha ocurrido en venezuela radio
más allá de esta situación es evidente
que una de las situaciones más
preocupantes es la de méxico por el
alto número de periodistas que han sido
asesinados en lo que va del año
y es una situación la de la violencia
contra periodistas que se repite por un
lado desde el lado del narco en muchos
casos con complicidad con gobiernos
locales o federales o estatales
se repite digo en honduras en guatemala
misma en colombia en brasil son
situaciones realmente preocupantes y que
en muchos casos no hay un firme
compromiso de los estados para ponerle
costo no es por el contrario
en el caso de andrés manuel lópez
obrador en méxico o de jair bolsonaro en
brasil hay una permanente
estigmatización al periodismo en
permanente confrontación con el
periodismo que es otra de las
situaciones que se repite desde uno u
otro modo en todo el continente
pero hay múltiples situaciones que se
están reproduciendo además por violencia
en manifestaciones callejeras en
programas sociales
donde también las fuerzas policiales no
dan
suficientes garantías para el ejercicio
del periodismo en estos días en la misma
el mismo país donde estoy en argentina
hubo una foto tomada por un reportero
gráfico que muestra el preciso instante
en que le disparan un balazo que por
suerte por fortuna no dio contra él pero
él y otro colega fueron baleados en el
momento en que estaban cubriendo esos
acontecimientos y lo mismo ocurrió en
chile hace poco donde falleció
lamentablemente una colega en una
protesta callejera no